okay Black is going with the copycat
variation and pawn up no wait a second
which I need me I want to go for III and
d4 it's different let's try it black
isn't careful if they're just going to
play knight c6 and allow me to maintain
upon D 441 move and then press forward
that could be a big problem so right now
after this I think I'd better go with
the first first off let's get this in
and now we're going to be seeing d5 so
what is this transposing into it looks
like we have a line out of the caro-kann
enough Bob panic attack but um is this
like rego Rogozin ish um let's see what
are you doing response to this move was
Queen check its Bishop d3 I think Bishop
d3
yeah let's go a vision d 3 ah ok this
castle get out of the pin I can be hit
with our saddled with an isolated Queen
pond at any moment this exchange could
occur I can throw a question this bishop
but well actually that's something to
look into maybe because maybe before
that I give black an opportunity to go
with the structural change like if I do
18 it runs away maybe I could go forward
c5 and then I'm in a spot to support c5
with be four although after a 3 there is
d take C and then the bishop could run
away I think it's ok let me do it right
now let's see what black is going to do
would they give up the bishop for night
are they going to run away are they
going to throw in an in-betweener those
are three candidate moves i think that
black has here Queen a 5 i'm not too
afraid of it just prevents Bishop takes
pawn for a move after Bishop d2 then
they have to answer a question in now
I'm seriously giving consideration to
changing the structure and establishing
a three-to-two majority on the queenside
now if there's a drawback with that the
one thing I'm going to be looking into
is maybe a central push by black because
if I'm going to end up with a three to
two majority on the queenside that
implies that black is going to have a
two-to-one majority in the center and
off to look into the e5 move and see if
it's going to work out well for black
I'm not castled yet but ok just to sing
them away not that far off if I play be
four right now there once again is the
possibility for taking and
maybe I don't want to even allow that
I'm going to try and see how it works
see how black deals with this structural
change ok be4 could be played with tempo
let me do that right now i think ii five
could get played by force so should I
kick this night away hmm maybe I should
do that before it's in a spot to to
facilitate this e5 advance however
better move quick that's one thing
another thing is that maybe black has a
good move here maybe they could have
just ignored the threat on the night
plate here with the fork in mind so let
me get castled so these guys are pretty
far advanced and well now this pawn is a
beast however after a six and maybe I
shouldn't have done that move i think a
six is good but now it's not so good i
wouldn't have had this a4 move in
response to a six but now I now I'm in a
spot to to be able to do that let me see
where does my dark square Bishop belong
I think I want to keep my rook here I
did think about Bishop to this square
but i don't know i think i just want to
recapture the pond this is a difficult
it's difficult to get this guy working i
want to kind of weasel my dark square
Bishop around rookie one is purposeful
let's do this if pond push I could take
the night and only then recapture on the
e queen d 6 is interesting if I control
this pawn push I control this Bishop
that's one way to look at this position
controlling a pond push may turn out to
be controlling this Bishop queen is
getting ready to line up here i think i
just take here and pot and throw my
night into this square I think that's
best I'm giving up my light square
Bishop but but what here one of the
things to question is if you give up
your light square Bishop will your
opponent's light square Bishop give you
beating and I don't think that that's
going to happen if this if this pond
can't move because these two guys knock
out all three of these squares a 6 b 7 d
7 and if this pond can't move the bishop
is dead so control this square is the
main idea sometimes there'll be a 97
move I'm also stopping that this is a
connected past pond quite deep in the
black territory one minute having to
fight back timewise bishop here Bishop
g3 just to keep things nice and cozy
control over a five okay let's get there
right now the guy on let's just no slip
there my mouse lip I mean my mouth
literally almost just slipped off of my
mouse pad Bishop g3 I guess in response
tonight move here I could end up with
two knights versus two bishops well this
Bishop is proving to just end up like
there's a disconnect between those guys
let's a challenge that rook before it
gets excited about coming down to a
three or a four putting pressure on my
night it's very difficult to get rid of
this guy with f6 with an f6 move because
I always have a Knight takes pawn so I
might as well pre-move this there's
nothing better about a minute advantage
okay well I can also go with getting the
Queen's off the board but you know what
after i take this rook the bishops
unprotected so i have tricks Knight
takes pawn is available with check can
have a pond and now i have a dark square
Bishop that'll be able to conveniently
watch over this e5 square and i think
once again just challenging any black
piece that tries to get control of the a
file is a good idea even in an opposite
color bishop ending for example night
here takes takes having just a Bishop
and pawn here again once again
controlling e6 is controlling the game
and now I could actually go for more
material I could get b6 and I don't
think that there's any hurry yeah
there's no hurry with that I guess pawn
push is available just to free up the
position and just giving that up gotta
go quick go quick I could have seen a
line where I can maybe just give up my
night in order to put oh my pawn right
here in particular takes rook takes I
just come behind my pond I wasn't seeing
that line though let's make sure I get a
flight square get a flight square before
it's too late pawn push is available ok
now it's not available King up King up
where's my time done it's a wonderful
question i don't know that i have a good
answer to it other works really going to
come off i really wouldn't happen i can
maybe get a mate the king is too
reckless it could be mate real soon
kingi for King g4 is mate not going
there where'd my time go
where did it go tricky checks let's pre
move let's do this it's an easy prey
move to make my bishop right here trade
rooks number up trade trade it is back
up okay time time time time I wasted a
lot of time on that one but I'm pretty
sure I kept control over it but there
were opportunities in that middle game
for my opponent I believe good game
let's flip this and go through it
quickly ah what's the scoop here what
about in this position okay so i have
this Bishop d4 line right now again I'm
just throwing it out there for my pony
after if they're listening now and also
again for those that might just be
jumping in and weren't listening when I
was playing it live but you could I
think as black consider taking here and
then running back to e7 that's one thing
and once again right here I think there
might even be a possibility for 94 I
didn't reference this during the game
but maybe there's something with a 94
right here I push you go back you're
getting ready for that 'if I've break
and right now I think this is another
possibility I think you end up losing a
pond though so maybe not be five if I
take your nut you push forward efore
you're getting your minor piece back but
after I take you recapture I end up okay
i'll be up upon but i thought that that
was interesting did I allow you okay I
allowed this right here's another
opportunity to break at this structure
if I'm allowed to maintain this it's
just overwhelming and it was present for
the remainder of the game this structure
you do have one opportunity to break at
this b5 c6
structure with a six right now you move
the rook but now it's too late when you
break at it because I could get an A for
and rook here I'm out of any pin along
the a file etc so very time sensitive
when it comes to breaking at that
structure after c6 do it right now with
a six but the earliest suggestion
because I think from right from from out
there not excuse me it's a very uphill
battle I control e5 and I think I'm
controlling the game at that point so
look into that a six move right away
should you get into that position and
also this right here instead of reacting
right away to the threat consider takes
and then coming back to let's say e7
anticipating let's say an eventual pin
on g5 just kind of going back and
working against this isolated pawn on
the d4 square anyhow those are some of
my thoughts right there some of my
suggestions ok good game let's close out